Hey, how's it going bros; My name is PewDiePie (BTW where's the loud ass windows intro???!?!?)
This week, I'm in Italy. We're at the beach right now. (I know a lot of beaches *wink*)
It's really nice
Just taking a couple days off (Marzia touching her hair to poods neck in the back)
Marzia, what are you doing?
I'm just gonna kinda
Low-key vlog the trip
Just like what we're doing
Stuff like that
Do you wanna swim?
[yee]
Let's go
It's really nice
Just gonna try not to drop my phone cause it's my only vlogging camera
Jesus Christ
What is this hair?
Why am I a mushroom?
Honestly
Not flexing at all
Okay
So hey
How's it going?
Just gonna go in the water now
[pirate music] dem mucles tho
[nice back]
[look at that run]
[can we get a replay on that?]
[instant replay in slow motion]
[beautiful form 12/10]
*trust falls with ocean*
[moaning intensifies]
Being [a] vlogger is the worst
[being a subtitler is even worsterer]
[same guys]
[true dat]
Too much, man
That was a joke
I am doing nothing
Ayoow Youtube
Welcum to mah crib
This is ma castle
Ma million dolla castle
I live in dis towa
This is where Marzia lives
I'm honestly just trying to make this video 10 minutes (by) at this point
[get that ad revenue]
Of course
I can't make it one...
...one day in the sun without becoming a lobster
Can really see-e-e it
Swedish genes: They're just the best
Not the genes... the jeans?
The jeenz
Whatever
Okay I'm gonna go for a run now
Alright
Ba-bye
[moans]
Okay...
Feel stupid
The is ridiculou-
[more running]
Oh man
Is that smudgy? (not at all only my vision is compromised)
I reached the end
I guess i'll go back
[Panting]
I think that was 8 kilometers or something
Correction that was probably more like 200 kilometers
just to be clear
Holy shit
[More Panting]
I'm not use to running in that heat man
that was fucking brutal
i'm gonna take a cold shower
You can imagine me naked if you want thats ok (Will do sir atleast the fangirls will)
So, I took a shower
Put on a new Shirt
Sat down for 5 Minutes
This happened. (Pewds laughing)
whats that baby doing there?
*sexual doll* aww you look so nice and sweaty pewds hehe
Doll: Can I shower with you pew-  *Pewds shakes his head*
pewds: egh weird joke ok
I guess I need a new shower
we just had dinner.. super late its..
Pewds: omg Marzia: its not that late Pewds: its 9:30 thats super late
Pewds I need to go to sleep  man, sorry marzia (B-b-but Marzia wants to hang with you pewds )
Ok bye now goodnight
Marzia: Bye.  Pewds: first day in italy i'll see you tomorrow
*Pewds makes weird sound*
(Man if only you guys know how long it is to do captions)
[Yea, can we subtitlers get some monay from pewds?]
Ok so day 2
were just checking out some places out in italy
i dont really know where we are
umm
But its very pretty
*bells ringing in the backround* Pewds: would you look at that
*bells still ringing* *I'm crying, it's so butiful ( ຈ ﹏ ຈ )
*pewds makes a sound*
*laughing*
I forgot how hot this country is i am literally melting (don't come to india you'll crash and burn)
This is no place for a sweed (swedish person)
I dont like it (come to australia)
Am i doing it?
Marzia: Yeah
Pewds: is it good?
Marzia: its-Yeah (lying game on point)
Pewds: does it look good?
Marzia: yeah (God damn it pewds she says yeah)
*Cute Marzia Giggling
*sweet background music*
(Nice towers)
[Yea, the people can see that, other subtitler...]
(Ok people walking nice)
Okk...
Those are coming from the nipples
*Marzia talking about something*
Pewds the boob fountain? Marzia: Yeah
*Pewds speaking another language* *more laughing*
Atleast I have my thumbnail sorted out (Perv)
Its perfect
(Oh god pewds)
[Holy shit is that sexy]
(Only do that to marzia or off camera god)
Look at this nerd (Who marzia or the man?)
Stupid nerd-OH SHE CAN HERE US abort (RED ALERT RED ALERT CODE RED!)
Oh architecture look at that [Yea, very amazed]
That's so cool
ayyyyyyyyyy 8)///
Oh they're cuming here [oh yea]
OMG
Super fast [Sonic-Duck confirmed]
C'mon
C'mon bud I'll save you [Pewds the savior JESUS]
Pewds is laughing [Aww :) //]
This is definatly  my face when i see ducks
( Dat face)
Maybe you didnt know this but we use to live in italy for awhile
And this is where we would sleep (O_O)
And marzia- *Laughter*  (Marzia what huh? :o)
Felix: this is- Marzia: look its popop thats popo
Felix: no one cares about popop (I do :'(  )
Marzia: well..
I like how you have a coco cola
that's like- oh thats the Marzia one
I drank this once when I was like  really desperate (that's like always)
Marzia: OMG WHAT! (how dare he!)
Marzia: YOU'RE
TERRIBLE!
Felix: this is my corner
My headlamp which i would always keep
I needed it
Marzia: Mhm
Pewds: I like how your mom saved all this stuff
My uh very cool wristband (So cool senpai)
Which I of course would wear all the time (Yeah right)
*Marzia background noises*
you know your cool when you have one (so i'm not cool? ;-;)
*Slight laughter*
Pewds: I found this
I was like why the hell would i have saved this
this is a famous uh swedish guy (Nice face xD)
but it says from love- with love marzia so (Daww melix is real)
Marzia: Thats art
my very cool brofist (Omg I remember that bracelet)
Marzia: Yeah Felix: I would wear this all the time
I found my old notebook (say what now?)
Kill Marzia? (Of course pewds xD)
Guess I failed on that one (you failed terribly on that one)
Play Amnesia Custom  Story (Rip Amnesia ;-;)
Fridays with pewdiepie (Rip ;-;)
Those were the days (The best days ever ;-;)
I wanna go down to my office (OMG DO IT PEWDS :D)
"My Office"
Does anyone recognize? (Omfg the memories in this place)
were we are (We all do pewds)
Omg [SAMEEEE THE FEELSS]
Jesus Christ (I know pewds ;-;)
There
This is where pewdiepie started (Omg the nostalgia is real ;-;)
this is where pewdiepie
became the biggest channel (;-;)
On the internet (im so happy for you poods)
In a place were barely had internet (Barely had good lighting too miss those days)
*Shakes head*
there use to be so many bugs down here like really big ones (eww o_o)
omg
So ya like I had it pretty nice
I would keep my playstation  here on the stove (Genius pewds lol)
*cringy giggles*
oh man dude this takes me back
*ukelele music plays*
[WHOA OMG R THOSE ABS, OMG SENPAI]
[dat dive tho]
[is he dead]
[OH JESUS THAT HAIR THO]
[Cheerful music]
sorry
I, um.. my battery died yesterday
so I didn't vlog anything else
but we're going to Gardaland now
which is like Disneyland for Italian people
except everything is copyrighted
I don't know how they get away with it. (Why don't you ask taylor swift)
It's really cool though, I'm really excited.
I've been here once before.
I'll take you around some rides. I'll take you for a ride baby.
[Whispers] You just can come with me it's gonna be fine. Just hold my hand and feel safe.
[Abrasive amusement park rock music]
This theme park doesn't play around!
IT'S HARDCORE.
Oh my god, they want you to have a seizure before you enter!
I swear that's Tony The Tiger.
[indistinct chatter]
...and that's someone on drugs.
This is like... The dankest... kids place-- [pewds laughs]
I really wanna go on this one.
[Background chatter]
Ahahaha!
[Roller coaster riders scream]
Oh my god [laughs]
Uhhhh... I've never been on this one! I don't know what--- Oh my god!
Well that doesn't look too bad. Haha!
Oh boy. OH BOY. OH NO. WHOOOAAA AAAAAHHHHHHHH
[Whistling and cheering] DAT FACE THO
That is way too close man... Way too close dude.
WTF WAS THAT NOISE?
[Screams]
[Screams Again]
[Cheerful Ukulele music plays]
Beautiful picture. [Pewds laughs]
Marzia [Chuckling] She's gonna kill me.
---OHHH! HOLY SHIT THAT'S ACTUALLY HIGH
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHH! URRRRRRGGHHH!
OH! WHA! WHA! WHAAA!
I'm on... one percent battery. But today was really fun and I'll see you tomorrow!
Goodbye!
Okay. Final day in Italy. We're going to this place that Marzia describes as mind blowing.
This is her city... and she told me to vlog it so I'll check it out I guess. I don't really know. [chuckle]
Ohhhhh..wooooow.
That's really cool.
[sighs] This is very cool.
I don't know what it is though.. [chuckles]
[whispers] look at the ceiling and everything... Amazing
Just thought I'd film some more buildings in case you haven't seen enough buildings..
Theres a couple more.
Here we got [an] epic view!
Very nice.
Okay, I didn't vlog the last day
I'm sorry. We're going home now. It's raining so it fits.
I had a really good trip. It was really fun. I felt like I needed... a little break.
Even though I still-- I still vlog a little bit.
But I'm glad you bros got [to] come along
I got to spend more time with Marzia
Which is really nice as well and uhhh--  yeah...
Hope you bros enjoyed this vlog. [Marzia makes high pitched noise then laughs]
Please leave a like if you did and let me know if you want more of these
And Ill be sure to vlog if I ever go somewhere
and as always... Stay awesome bros!
[Cheerful ukulele music plays]
[Credits to all people who did the subtitles is in the description.]
[Have a good day everyone! Or night? I don't know! Just be happy! :)]
[Cheerful music continues]
[Music stops, Marzia screams]
OHHH THAT IS... HOW DOES THAT EXISSSSSSTAUGGHH